c'est l'heure du second débat de ce sens
public comme chaque semaine avant les
élections sénatoriales du dimanche 24
septembre notez ça sur vos agendas on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler évidemment
vous propose un zoom sur les enjeux de
ce scrutin le contre-pouvoir de la
chambre haute l'impact des commissions
d'enquête le portrait robot des
candidats les nouvelles stars attendues
beaucoup de thèmes abordés mais d'abord
notre reportage au cœur de la campagne
électorale dans le Nord Jonathan du
priez et Samya déchire pardon je vais me
faire taper sur les doigts on est dans
le Pas-de-Calais
allez prenez place bah j'ai pas vu
j'étais en avant l'expérience de leur
duo Jean-François Rapin tête de liste à
droite et à melgacker numéro 2 pour
l'UDI vise deux sièges dans le
Pas-de-Calais ce jour-là épaulé par
Xavier Bertrand il présente leurs
projets à 90 grands électeurs principal
atout leur appartenance à la majorité
sénatoriale avant une année chargée au
Parlement on va redémarrer la session
parlementaire avec des textes très
lourds sur l'immigration sur la fin de
vie qui sont des textes où vous avez
besoin d'avoir des gens qui sont sur
deux jambes qui ont l'assise prête mais
Jean-François Rapin c'est la campagne au
moins lisible qu'il y a 6 ans du fait
d'un paysage politique éclaté 4000
grands électeurs éparpillés dans 890
communes dont les deux tiers sont sans
étiquette politique difficile donc de ce
hasard et à des pronostics quand vous me
demandez si effectivement c'est la même
chose qui a 6 ans non j'ai pas
l'impression
on est quand même dans une campagne
beaucoup plus de proximité beaucoup plus
de corps à corps et avec au compteur
beaucoup de kilomètres qui s'affichent
parce que les gens nous demandent de la
proximité face à Jean-François Rapin se
dresse un obstacle au centre la liste
moderne renaissance de Jean-Marie
Vandenberg à 84 ans le doyen du Sénat
ancien maire d'Arras a décidé de se
relancer rassurez-vous moi aussi je
pensais ne pas jouer les prolongations
et puis on est venu me solliciter
des mères importants je suis à la tête
d'un commando mon attention c'est pas de
prolonger indéfiniment il est évident
mais de les entraîner je connais
évidemment bien le département tu vas
bien le duo quittable sur son expérience
des affaires sociales espère aussi faire
la différence grâce à sa numéro 2
Brigitte bourguignon ancienne ministre
de la Santé macroniste issue du PS mais
la bataille s'annonce rue au vu des
divisions de la droite et du centre car
en plus d'une liste LR une autre réputée
proche du mouvement horizon s'est lancé
dans la course
ici je trouve toujours dommage que
certains n'est toujours pas compris dans
notre département il était plus qu'utile
d'agir ensemble que de partir dispersés
parce qu'on sait très bien à qui profite
toujours la dispersion ces divisions
pourraient aider Christopher Zurich à
faire son entrée au Sénat à 38 ans le
candidat proche de Marine Le Pen
représente l'une des meilleures chances
du RN de faire son come-back au Palais
du Luxembourg permet pas vraiment
l'impression parce que je fais ma je
fais mon petit bonhomme de cheveux entre
guillemets je fais une vraie motivation
en revanche évidemment à ce que le RN
revienne au Sénat parce que je pense
qu'il y a vraiment qu'aujourd'hui le
premier adjoint à la mairie
d'Hénin-Beaumont se dit candidat du réel
est mise sur une campagne rurale
discrète pour séduire les quelques 650
merci sans étiquette du département moi
je fais des rendez-vous individuels
parce que je pense aussi que c'est ce
qu'ils attendent de nous c'est-à-dire un
contact direct beaucoup de mer ne disent
parfois soit qu'ils ont pas forcément
beaucoup vu le sénateurs durant les 6
dernières années soit de manière
générale il se sente un peu un peu
abandonné moi je j'ai envie de leur
prêter aussi une oreille à une voix si
vous voulez
la communiste Katia pour sopoli veut
justement être l'un des remparts au RN
et notamment dans le bassin minier où
l'extrême droite possède ses bastions la
sénatrice capitalise sur son expérience
à la commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat et sa forte présence sur le
terrain avec plus de 600 communes
visitées durant son mandat moi je ne
suis pas juste dans une période
électorale ça fait cinq ans que je
laboure le terrain en tant que sénatrice
ça fait depuis 2014 oui je labourre le
bassin minier pour la rénovation et donc
une élection pour moi ne va pas changer
les choses la tête de liste PCF mise
aussi sur l'ouverture avec le divers
gauche Jean-Pierre corbizet en numéro 2
sur sa liste nous sommes retrouvés sur
la réforme des retraites nous nous
sommes retrouvés sur le projet de loi
discrétaire de mairie nous nous
retrouvons sur lasagne finalement on
s'est dit punir nos forces pour le
département avec une liste qui
représente l'ensemble du département
parce que nous avons des
postiers qui sont sur l'ensemble du
département une liste donc
départementale j'insiste sur ça uni et
donc tout naturellement nous avons
décidé de travailler ensemble en
l'absence d'une liste d'union de la
gauche les socialistes se sont lancés
seuls dans la bataille avec Jérôme
d'Arras premier adjoint de la mairie de
Liévin et ancien en fonctionnaires
territoriale et la sénatrice sortante
Sabine vanègles sous la bannière MRC
j'ai déjà l'expérience d'un mandat ça
change la physionomie de la de la
campagne parce qu'on a on a des choses à
dire sur notre bilan et on a aussi un
recul le recul nécessaire pour pouvoir
parler au maire
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
si le PS peut tabler sur ces bons
résultats aux dernières municipales pour
faire au moins siège le risque
d'éparpillement est grand en plus des
communistes et les filles et les
écologistes conduisent eux aussi des
listes concurrentes là le choix était
fait pour ces élections sénatoriales de
partir en liste séparée parce que nous
estim ons que cela serait plus clair
vis-à-vis des grands électeurs nous nous
sommes pour la clarté nous nous sommes
une liste socialiste citoyenne affirmer
comme tel nous sommes les représentants
de la gauche des solutions avec Willis
au total et de nombreuses divisions
entre la droite le centre et la gauche
et avec un RN en embuscade l'élection du
24 septembre promet d'être scrutés dans
le Pas-de-Calais
les enjeux des sénatoriales et notamment
se contrepouvoir que représente la
chambre haute au coeur de notre débat
avec Nathalie Moret bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
politique au groupe Ebra groupe de
plusieurs titres de la presque
quotidienne régionale Bruno cotreize
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue Bruno
polytologue chercheur au CNRS et
Guibert bonsoir vous êtes le président
de la Fabrique écologique auteur de ce
livre le grand malentendu climatique
publié aux Éditions de l'Aube vous avez
été élu au Mans et à mulsan dans la
Sarthe et donc vous avez été grand
électeur vous pourrez lui partager votre
expérience Mathieu croissant
à mes côtés Nathalie m'aurait ces
élections séatoriales elles sont
paradoxales on va pas se mentir un même
ici à Public Sénat elle n'intéresse pas
forcément le grand public et pourtant à
plus d'un titre inscritain intéressant
quels sont les pour vous les les enjeux
justement qu'il faut relever autour de
ça intéresse pas énormément les gens
puisque
Gérard Larcher rester le président du
Sénat puisque les mêmes équilibres
politiques vont rester c'est normal
aussi que que les gens ne soient pas
forcément intéressés par cette élection
puisqu'il y a que la moitié des
départements qui sont renouvelés donc
dans la moitié du territoire
effectivement c'est une action qui passe
sous les radars et puis nous n'irons pas
voter le 24 septembre et un autre
élément important démonstration
activement ce sont les grands électeurs
vous en parlerai peut-être qui qui
lisent les sénateurs ça reste une une
élection qui est
hyper intéressante à mon sens puisque le
diable étant dans les détails il va
falloir voir quels sont les groupes qui
sortent renforcés de cette élection ceux
qui ont sorte à moins de riz je vous
donne un exemple par exemple le groupe
horizon qui n'existait pas il y a six
ans lors de enfin de l'élection qu'on
peut comparer
depuis il est en train de se mailler sur
tout le territoire sur les l'échelon de
la commune donc il y aura énormément de
grands électeurs qui sont horizons donc
c'est une forme de test pour Édouard
Philippe
cas c'est une occasion pour lui d'avoir
plusieurs
sénateurs dans les zones où il est fort
par exemple chez dans le Maine-et-Loire
chez
le tome de Christophe Vichy ou si elle a
robinet à Reims ça c'est la première
chose en plus depuis les dernières
élections
municipales il y a eu des merveilles
beaucoup des mères écologistes donc on
devrait voir le groupe écologiste avoir
plusieurs plusieurs sénateurs et puis
enfin dernière chose quid du
rassemblement national là pour l'instant
ils n'ont pas d'élus ils en avaient un
mais qui est devenu non inscrit est-ce
qu'il va y avoir un deux ou trois voire
quatre et lui du rassemblement national
si jamais c'était le cas au soir du 24
septembre ce serait un mini événement
c'est-à-dire peu de poids politique mais
un mini événement le roi rassemblement
national qui rentre au Sénat et on sera
évidemment là pour vous faire vivre
cette journée du 24 septembre journée
spéciale sur la tête de Public Sénat
Bruno que 13 il y a aussi un enjeu
d'exposition médiatique d'une certaine
façon pour le Sénat on peut dire oui un
contestablement vous savez le ce que ce
que peu de d'électricité d'électeurs
savent c'est quel est le rôle du Sénat
beaucoup s'interroge c'est quoi un
sénateur d'où ça sort comment ça a été
élu
il faut à nouveau se servir je pense de
ces élections sénatoriales pour rappeler
l'importance de la deuxième chambre dans
un système démocratique vous savez c'est
ce qu'on appelle les parlementarisme
bicaméraux avec deux chambres la fameuse
chambre basse et la chambre haute la
chambre basse qui représente la voie du
peuple l'Assemblée nationale la chambre
haute qui représente au fond les
territoires ou la société civile en
France on a le Conseil économique et
social aussi pour la société civile mais
ça participe de ce qu'on appelle un bon
équilibre des pouvoirs c'est-à-dire que
tout le pouvoir ne peut pas être
concentré dans les mains d'une seule
personne d'une seule assemblée il y a
des régimes
fondamental en régime démocratique il y
a des contre-pouvoirs et le Sénat il est
là pour eux aussi se contre-pouvoir pour
rappeler l'importance des territoires
pour être une chambre de qui vient
tempérer un petit peu vous savez que le
Sénat est réputé pour être le lieu du
consensus du dialogue apaisé du dialogue
politique enfin apaisé par rapport à
l'Assemblée nationale ben la
terriblement besoin dans un régime
démocratique de ce bon équilibre les
choses et donc un gros enjeu de pédag
elle contrastine entre la zone et le
Sénat et évidemment de plus en plus fort
en tout cas sur les 18 derniers mois
Jérôme Guibert votre expérience donc ce
sont les grands électeurs qui votent
comment ça se passe vous vous
bien comprendre c'est que c'est pour ça
que le grand public doit aussi un peu
s'intéresser à ces élections ces
élections qui représentent les
territoires et donc évidemment ce sont
les élus locaux qui qui élisent les
sénateurs mais on voit bien que il y a
une logique de représentation du
territoire et en particulier des régions
rurales et périurbaines qui est assez
important dans un système démocratique
parce que il y a des vrais logiques de
territoire et qu'il était nécessaire
qu'elle soit prise en compte dans les
décisions publiques et c'est vrai que
c'est assez frappant de voir moi j'ai
vécu dans donc dans une vie centre et
ensuite dans une commune périurbaine
donc le monde d'abord mulsan ensuite et
donc vous avez dans une ville centre une
élection qui est en fait très politique
puisque vous avez des des listes
politiques et des délégués des conseils
Mitaux vous savez des conseils
conseiller municipaux qui vote mais vous
avez aussi des délégués qui votent et
les délégués c'est généralement des
militants ou des gens très engagés
politiquesment et donc vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de surprises ça veut dire qu'on
voit le candidat de son parti ça veut
dire qu'on vote pour le candidat de son
parti donc ça c'est pour la ville centre
en revanche dans une ville Péru urbaine
ou rurale ou le choix politique est
beaucoup plus s'estompe beaucoup plus il
y a beaucoup de mer sans étiquettes sans
étiquettes à ce moment-là le le la
rencontre il y a deux facteurs me
semblent-ils qui jouent la rencontre des
candidats avec les électeurs et qui
jouent un rôle assez important et il y a
aussi la façon dont le sénateur peut se
positionner par rapport à quelques
sujets importants du territoire et c'est
vrai que ça ça compte aussi évidemment
beaucoup dans le choix qui peut être
fait est-ce que le sénateur va soutenir
telle ou tel projet d'équipement qui est
important pour la collectivité est-ce
qu'il va soutenir une politique plus de
par exemple de reconquête des des
friches parce que voilà enfin il y a
toute une série de sujets comme ça et
qui évidemment sont importants
[Musique]
moins bien représenté moins bien incarné
moi bien défendu sans le Sénat
sans doute qu'il faut en tout cas dans
un régime démocratique une assemblée qui
prend en compte effectivement cette
dimension territoriale qui est toujours
très importante dans tous les pays bien
évidemment et dans toutes les
démocraties européennes il y a une
deuxième chambre qui va prendre en
compte soit le poids des régions soit le
poids des territoires et donc c'est vrai
que c'est très important puisque la
fabrique de la politique publique est
l'objectif ultime du Parlement Assemblée
nationale et Sénat la fabrique de la
politique publique elle débouche
toujours sur des mises en oeuvre
territorialisées des acteurs
territoriaux qui doivent les incarner
qui doivent s'en saisir qu'il s'agisse
de du territoire vu par l'État les
préfets qui s'agissent des territoires
vus par les collectivités territoriales
par les acteurs économiques locaux donc
oui je pense que cette dimension
territoriale elle est tout à fait
essentielle en démocratie et tout le
coeur du sujet c'est justement le bon
maillage en tout cas le bon
fonctionnement entre la représentation
dite nationale
issue des élections législatives et
cette autre chambre qui a une composante
le territoire est plus importantes le
Parlement l'Assemblée nationale dans sa
composante le Parlement et sa composante
Assemblée nationale n'est pas non plus
totalement aveugle à la dimension bien
sûr il y a 577 circonscriptions
législatives et elle-même elles sont
représentatives de certains territoires
mais là on a un niveau territorial qui
est intéressant c'est celui du
département comme circonscription
d'élection et ça fait une certaine
différence avec les circonscriptions de
l'Assemblée nationale un éclairage alors
médiatique évidemment je retournerai de
nouveau vers votre analyse politique
mais un gros comme le groupe Ebra c'est
ces élections sénatoriales c'est dans
les pages locales c'est dans les pages
nationales les deux mon capitaine alors
pour l'instant ce sont dans les pages
locales parce qu'effectivement nous
notre zone de diffusion est tellement
vaste qu'il y a une partie des
départements pas mal d'ailleurs qui sont
renouvelables et pas les autres donc
toute la campagne j'allais dire
fabrication d'hélice présentation des
listes etc c'est vraiment sur
Républicain Lorrain et ce républicain
Dauphiné pour ne pas citer les journaux
et ensuite à partir de la semaine
prochaine on va décliner plusieurs
dossiers sur le Sénat son rôle son rôle
croissant d'ailleurs et les enjeux de
cette élection qui sera là cette fois-ci
au niveau national dans tout dans tous
les journaux alors ce scrutin il est
d'autant plus intéressant que le Sénat
est un contre-pouvoir qui s'affirme de
plus en plus Mathieu on peut même dire
que depuis la réélection des manuel
Macron on n'a jamais autant parlé du
Sénat oui c'est une sacrée revanche pour
le palais du Luxembourg une institution
de notre démocratie Bruno kotresse le
rappelait qui a pourtant souvent été
malmené sous la 5ème république du
général de Gaulle qui envisagea de à la
fois changer sa composition et son rôle
avec le succès qu'on sait à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui lui proposa dans son
programme présidentiel carrément de le
supprimer sous les deux Lionel juste
pour un Premier ministre qui considérait
que parlait d'anomalies démocratique en
raison du mode du scrutin qui lui est
peu représentatif de de l'ensemble de la
société ou Emmanuel Macron qui
s'interrogeait aussi sur la
transformation du Sénat ça c'était après
le mouvement des gilets jaunes vous vous
souvenez il y avait les propositions de
référendum citoyen pour
supprimer le Sénat en fait le Sénat a
souvent été dans le collimateur des
politiques eux-mêmes au-delà des
railleries et des parfois des moqueries
des humoristes et parfois de la
différence de la population et pourtant
depuis c'est vrai un an un peu plus d'un
an même le Sénat bénéficie d'un vrai
retour de flamme retour de flamme
comment vous l'expliquez mais il le doit
à la fois à lui-même et au circonstances
survie de dire d'abord à lui-même parce
qu'il s'est affirmé au fil des années
comme un véritable contre-pouvoir on en
parlait aussi en assumant pleinement sa
mission de contrôle de l'action de
l'exécutif et du gouvernement
particulier et ce vraiment beaucoup
depuis 2017 notamment à travers ces
fameuses commissions d'enquête vous vous
souvenez à faire Benalla enquête sur les
cabinets de conseil fiasco du Stade de
France beaucoup plus récemment le front
Marianne tous les Français en ont
entendu parler le sérieux de ses
commissions d'enquête à chaque fois a
fait mouche tout le monde peut se
féliciter du travail parlementaire qui a
été accompli et puis les questions
précises et sans concession des
sénateurs qui sont maintenant transmises
à la télé et bien font trembler plus
d'un officiel ou d'un ministre invité
sur le grill
ce sérieux qui est la marque de fabrique
du Palais du Luxembourg et qui se
traduit aussi vos locaux très en parler
dans sa façon de travailler la loi la
qualité de ses débat sans concession
mais avec modération et puis surtout
sans esbrooke j'ai envie de dire sans
vos se faire ration sans opposition
systématique tout ça en gros c'est le
miroir inversé de ce à quoi on a assisté
au Palais Bourbon notamment évidemment
tout le monde y pense lors des débats
sur la réforme des retraites du coup
c'est pas étonnant dans ces
circonstances et là on arrive aux
circonstances que l'exécutif lui
accorder soudain davantage de
considération parce que à la recherche
d'une majorité introuvable à l'Assemblée
nationale mais le gouvernement voit
désormais le Sénat comme une forme de
pôle de stabilité sur lequel s'appuyait
d'ailleurs plusieurs textes qui ont été
examinés en premier ça sera d'ailleurs
encore le cas pour le fameux projet de
loi le plus compliqué du quinquennat
celui sur l'immigration tout ça afin de
poser un jalon voir de dégager selon les
les termes une forme de consensus le
gouvernement en gros ils espèrent que
les sénateurs arrivent à se mettre
d'accord et que les députés suivront
sont pas dupe et ils sont bien contents
de ce rôle retrouvé et il compte bien
faire pression sur le gouvernement et
puis on s'est évidemment que vérité au
Palais du Luxembourg n'est pas forcément
vérité au Palais Bourbon merci beaucoup
Mathieu pour toutes ces explications je
reviens vers vous Bruno cotteresse sur
la navette
parlementaire législative c'est
inhabituel pourquoi c'est inhabituel que
le Sénat soit saisi en premier d'un test
législatif vous me posez une colle
institutionnelle mais
c'est vrai que normalement dans l'ordre
des choses compte tenu du fonctionnement
de nos institutions et de la préminence
au bout du compte de l'Assemblée
nationale sur le sur le Sénat parce
qu'il faut quand même rappeler à ceux
qui nous regardent que dans nos
institutions de la Cinquième République
avec cette navette parlementaire au bout
du compte
les choses ont été organisées pour que
la majorité présidentielle qui
normalement à la majorité des sièges à
l'Assemblée nationale nous ne sommes pas
dans cette situation aujourd'hui qu'au
bout du compte elle puisse avoir le
dernier mot par rapport aux
contre-pouvoirs Jésus du Sénat alors il
peut arriver que ça soit le Sénat qui
qui est la politesse en premier ça veut
pas dire pour autant que ça va se passer
plus simplement mais c'est vrai que
politiquement ça crée quelque chose de
très intéressant compte tenu de ce que
Mathieu croissanto viendra rappeler
c'est-à-dire l'absence de majorité pour
Emmanuel Macron et la tension très très
vigilante qu'elle exécutive pour le pour
le Sénat parce que ça lui permet de de
sentir les choses de ce qui se passe du
côté des républicains en particulier
alors effectivement on y reviendra dans
un instant mais je voudrais vous l'avez
ok Mathieu qu'on se concentre les uns
les autres sur le travail de ces
commissions d'enquête on va reprendre un
exemple celui de la commission d'enquête
sur les cabinets de conseils regardez
cet extrait du documentaire signé
Quentin calmé qui avait diffusé sur
notre antenne cabinet de conseils l'État
sous influence point d'interrogation ce
sont les premières secondes du
documentaire
c'est une enquête dont le Sénat le
secret c'est la dernière année tout a
commencé ici à l'ouest du Palais du
Luxembourg dans les bureaux du groupe
communiste
pendant 6 mois il est nécessaire à
travailler sur l'influence sur l'état
des cabinets de conseils privés elle
était la rapporteur d'une commission
d'enquête au retentissement national
[Musique]
8,6 millions de vues des centaines de
milliers de d'impact je sais pas comment
on appelle ça précisément c'était
effectivement assez
quelque part un peu vertigineux mais
vraiment vertigineux c'était donc ça
c'est un sujet qui a intéressé le
citoyen
vous êtes également magistrat à la Cour
des comptes
du haut de ce de ce rôle comment vous
analysez le travail de des commissions
moi j'ai eu la chance d'être auditionné
très souvent au titre de président de la
Fabrique écologique de temps en temps au
titre de la cour des et ce qui me frappe
le plus sans vouloir être désagréable
avec quiconque c'est que au Sénat vous
avez une approche extrêmement rigoureuse
qui auditionne non seulement les
principales parties prenantes d'intérêt
mais aussi des gens qui ont réfléchi un
certain nombre de sujets qui peuvent
apporter quelque chose non je parle des
commissions non pas uniquement des
commissions d'enquêtes mais des
commissions tout court le travail des
commissions tout court et ça c'est pas
très connu et pourquoi parce
qu'évidemment ils ont plus de
possibilités de prendre de la hauteur
sur un certain nombre de sujets et on
voit bien que du coup l'approche elle
est vraiment sur le fond au Sénat et
elle est vraiment pour discuter des
solutions possibles alors ensuite
qu'est-ce qui en effet ça c'est un autre
un autre aspect mais moi je trouve que
les débats dans les commissions en tout
cas celle où c'était j'étais auditionnée
auquel j'ai assisté m'ont paru beaucoup
plus
rigoureuse et prenant les choses de
peut-être de manière plus comment dire
plus intéressante et plus avec un angle
plus large que quand vous êtes à
l'Assemblée ou à l'Assemblée vous c'est
vraiment un texte de loi avec on vous
demande la vie sur tel ou telle
amendement sur tel ou tel etc et donc de
ce point de vue là je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas très connu
mais qui est vraiment à souligné Mathieu
ou bien
d'une certaine façon et qu'on est moins
dans la logique de partie godillot qu'on
trouve beaucoup plus au Palais Bourbon
au Palais du Luxembourg il y a des
sénateurs qui sont des esprits libres il
y a souvent des groupes parlementaires
qui ne votent pas d'un seul bloc parce
que chacun peut voter aussi en fonction
de sa philosophie de son orientation de
ce qu'il pense du sujet donc voilà on
est moins dans l'automatisme mais
nathaliement c'est quand même aussi une
ça peut être en tout cas une machine de
guerre politique
à la fois un signe de bon fonctionnement
démocratique et une machine de guerre
politique une commission d'enquête on
l'a vu regardez la commission d'enquête
sur Benalla non seulement cette
commission d'enquête a été je crois une
des premières à être aussi suivie en
France et en plus il y avait aussi la
même d'enquête à l'Assemblée nationale
et on voit qu'elle n'était pas du tout
menée de la même façon
absolue pour la majorité présidentielle
a pris la lumière d'une façon incroyable
et on voit bien que pour lui ça a été
politiquement une façon de s'imposer au
Sénat au sein de son groupe politique
donc les enjeux politiques sert on parle
des territoires on traite pas les
dossiers pareils au Sénat mais on n'est
jamais non plus ennemis de ses intérêts
politiques à cette époque commission
Benalla on a parlé d'une americanisation
dans le fait de médiatiser de filmer en
direct de diffuser en direct les
commissions d'enquête moi j'y vois un
progrès et vous bah moi aussi on ne peut
pas dire que la transparence n'est pas
un progrès au bout d'un moment on est
dans un pays où les gens votent de moins
en moins alors déjà au Sénat
effectivement ce sont les grands
électeurs qui votent et pas les
électeurs ordinaires j'allais dire donc
le fait de voir le travail législatives
le travail de de comment de
travail de mission d'information des
conditions d'enquête des commissions
de le voir en direct je trouve que c'est
absolument fondamental franchement Bruno
4S je pense aussi au fond les les
élections mécaniquement qui s'agissent
des élections suffrages direct Assemblée
nationale ou indirect Sénat
mécaniquement c'est la voix du peuple
qui s'exprime à travers ses élections
mais il s'agit aujourd'hui dans les
enjeux démocratiques d'une démocratie
qui semble un petit peu à bout de
souffle en tout cas avec un souffle un
peu court de faire rentrer le peuple à
nouveau c'est pas parce que il y a eu
les élections et que par définition le
peuple est l'un qu'il est véritablement
là et donc un vrai enjeu qui est de
faire rentrer le peuple dans les
assemblées et de manière en fait et donc
le fait de retransm diffuser de retrans
servir capital parce que ça participe à
une fonction de contrôle supplémentaire
sa socialise les gens ça leur montre que
font les institution et ce sont des
questions que tout le monde se pose nous
ici on suit l'actualité bien sûr mais
beaucoup se posent cette question que
que font-ils ils ont l'air travaillé
mais que font-ils exactement donc c'est
absolument fondamental et je voudrais
ajouter un point sur ce que produit le
Sénat c'est bon que les spectateurs le
sache il y a beaucoup de rapports qui
sont publiés et disponibles sur le site
du Sénèque qui sont souvent d'une très
grande richesse vous rappelez il y a
quelques années on avait eu un pont qui
s'était effondré en France une situation
dramatique et on découvre à ce moment-là
qui a longtemps le Sénat fait un rapport
qui dit un problème avec l'entretien des
ponts en France et qui même donnent le
nombre de ponts qui mériteraient examen
voire travaux voilà donc c'est très
intéressant sur le site du Sénat on peut
trouver des documents de rapport qui ont
été fait très intéressants et alors se
positionnement permet au Sénat d'aborder
un certain nombre de sujets sociétaux
d'avenir à mon avis pas tout à fait
suffisamment c'est à dire je pense que y
compris les sujets de changement
climatique de mutation démographique
de mutation numérique par exemple
devrait être davantage abordés mais je
prends l'exemple de l'IVG le Sénat a
joué un rôle tout à fait important voire
majeur dans le projet de loi
constitutionnel pour introduire les
végés dans la Constitution donc on voit
bien que il a saisi il a une mutation
qui qui fallait entériner qu'il fallait
confirmer et ça c'est vraiment son rôle
et je pense que plus il jouera ce rôle
là dans l'avenir mieux cessera et plus
en positionnement pourra se s'établir
pour aller dans votre sens j'ajoute que
le Sénat a fait une mission
d'information ou une mission
d'information sur les mères porteuses il
y a plus de 10 ans c'était un thème qui
était pas du tout dans dans l'actualité
beaucoup moins que maintenant c'était
bien avant le mariage pour tous et c'est
quand même le Sénat et pas l'Assemblée
nationale qui a porté ce débat là et qui
a fait des recherches sur ce thème et
d'ailleurs nous on s'appuie très
régulièrement mais puis on peut en
témoigner sur ces rapports pour faire
des débats dans tout l'influence du
porno sur les enfants c'est aussi un
rapport de sénatrice qui sont vraiment
engagés c'est enfin voilà c'est des
sujets de société c'est pas de la
poussière au Palais du Luxembourg c'est
un parlement qui est ancré dans le réel
si si on se penche là de nouveau sur les
les enjeux politiques on va dire de ce
scrutin sénatorial Nathalie Moret
on va pas faire un faux suspense le
parti LR de regarder la majorité et
Gérard Larcher redevenir à rester
président du Sénat est-ce qu'il y aura
quand même dans l'attitude du parti LR
vis-à-vis d'Emmanuel Macron pour vous il
y a un avant après élection sénatoriale
je suis pas sûr qu'il y aura un avant
après élection sénatoriale parce que
effectivement les équilibres n'en vont
pas changer mais il y a un avant après
juin 2022 c'est-à-dire élections
législative à l'Assemblée nationale ce
n'est pas un hasard si le texte
immigration a été déjà adopté par le
Sénat ici pourquoi ça a été parce
qu'effectivement le gouvernement
s'appuie plus sur sa droite donc là les
sénateurs l'ont adopté en commission
largement amender ce qui est une façon
de mettre la pression sur les LR à
l'Assemblée nationale qui infinie aura
le dernier mot donc c'est pas tant
l'élection du 24 qui change la donne
c'est
le fait que le gouvernement n'est pas de
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée Bruno
Macron une alliance
Emmanuel Macron bon on a déjà beaucoup
débattu de ça sur ce plateau notamment
au moment de la réforme des retraites on
a vu comment ça s'est terminé elle vous
semble
possible vous vous dites quoi le Sénat
enfin la majorité a l'air du Sénat va
pas forcément changer de stratégie c'est
à dire plutôt essayer de peser au cas
par cas texte par text oui pour le
moment on est dans ce dans cette
situation avec pas exactement peut-être
les mêmes positions des sénateurs LR et
des députés LR on l'a vu à plusieurs on
l'a vu à plusieurs reprises
l'absence de majorité absolue est un
problème
parce qu'on voit que malgré ce que dit
le gouvernement souvent à raison
d'ailleurs en disant qu'ils sont arrivés
à faire adopter des textes à géométrie
variables avec une majorité tantôt avec
l'abstention tantôt avec le soutien de
certains députés c'est quand même au
bout d'un moment un problème parce que
c'est le problème sur les sur les grands
textes l'an passé la loi de finances
adoptée aux 49-3 on a la loi de finance
qui arrive on peut bien voir le problème
politique et que dans un régime
démocratique le texte fondamental le
texte législatif fondamental
c'est-à-dire la loi de finances
sur quelques années ça pourrait être un
problème si ça n'est adopté qu'au 49-3
politiquement on voit bien qu'elle a
quelque chose qui qui coince qui qui va
pas et donc c'est un peu là où le bât
blesse même si l'activité parlementaire
continue d'exister avec le gouvernement
arrive bien sûr à faire adopter adopter
cet ex alors est-ce que à ce qu'après
une alliance avec elle est possible pour
le moment Emmanuel Macron a dit de
manière assez constante qu'il n'y
croyait pas à la coalition à l'allemande
ça on s'enferme dans une salle pendant
des semaines et on met au point ensemble
un programme de gouvernement mais il y a
quand même un moment donné il y a une
situation qui reste qui reste difficile
pour lui allez-y un mot là-dessus
tant qu'il n'y a pas en effet une
alliance formelle parce qu'elle existe
un jour je n'en sais rien je pense que
l'idée moi je suis pas sûr que l'idée de
passer par le Sénat et par une majorité
sur un texte au Sénat pour ensuite
basculer sur l'Assemblée nationale soit
opérationnelle l'exemple des retraites a
montré le contraire elle a montré même
que ça procuré des illusions tout à fait
tout à fait gênante je pense peut-être
que
une démarche qui serait d'un
rassemblement plus large autour d'un
certain nombre de textes y compris au
Sénat pourraient peut-être à mon avis
être plus opérationnel pour peser sur
l'assemblée bon alors je sais pas si
c'est faisable je sais pas mais vous
voyez ce que je veux dire cette idée qui
en effet qui est quand même
manifestement dans la tête de certains
de dire on va trouver avec la droite
sénatorielle une majorité et puis
ensuite comme ça ça va obliger les
députés LR à voter de la même façon je
pense pas que ce soit très intéressant
il y a peu de chance que ça marche bon
on a on était beaucoup là autour des
équilibres politiques on va maintenant
parler un peu plus des personnalités
politiques et je propose à Mathias ça
reste de nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
Mathias pour alors on va on va beaucoup
parler de chiffres une page statistique
en quelque sorte Mathias on peut
commencer par établir en quelque sorte
un portrait robot des candidats allez on
fait ça rapidement Thomas le candidat
moyen aux élections sénatoriales de 2023
et bien c'est un homme puisque
53,3% des candidats sont de sexe
masculin et puis ce même candidat type
et bien il a 55 ans Thomas avec quand
même des femmes de plus en plus
représentées oui il y a des progrès
indéniables sur cette question cette
année
46,7% des candidats sont des candidates
c'est la plus haute proportion depuis
1986 un chiffre et qui s'explique
notamment par le fait que la moitié qui
se renouvelle cette année à plus de
départements dont le scrutin est à la
proportionnelle et donc soumis à la
parité le précédent record remonte à
2017 les femmes représentées alors
45,54% des non mises au voie il y a un
petit bémol toutefois sur les 225 listes
en lice seuls 59 soit un peu plus du car
ont une femme à leur tête bon on va
parler des sujets qui fâchent aussi la
pyramide des âges dans tout ça et
doucement mais sûrement la diversité des
âges s'empare aussi du Palais du
Luxembourg ou en tout cas de ces
aspirants les très jeunes entre 24 et 29
ans représente
3,67% des candidats seulement ils sont
minoritaires la tranche la plus
importante reste celle des 60 69 ans il
représente
29,65 75% des candidats et puis l'autre
tranche qui commence un petit peu à
tirer la couverture c'est celle des 559
puisqu'il représente tout de même 26,49
% des candidats est-ce qu'on se sent
bien au Sénat bien il faut croire
puisque 70 % des sortants souhaitent
remplir parmi lesquels les uns des
boulonnables pour le président Gérard
Larcher les socialistes Laurence
Rossignol et Patrick canaire ou encore
l'écologiste Guillaume Gontard et puis
l'autre argument qui va dans le sens
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
primo-candidats on pense notamment à
Yannick Jadot Sonia baquet ou encore
Yann brossa alors justement ces
candidats sur les personnalités qui
pourraient faire leur entrée à la
Chambre haute ou marquer ses élections
dont on a choisi quatre le plus connu
sans doute c'est Yannick Jadot candidat
Europe Écologie Les Verts à Paris
beaucoup voit aussi dans cette
candidature un marche-pied en vue d'une
éventuelle voilà Yannick Jadot une
éventuelle
candidature aux municipales dans la
capitale je vais revenir tout ça et puis
on va continuer de dérouler un peu les
les personnalités Sonya bac S vous
l'avez cité la secrétaire d'État chargée
de la citoyenneté elle elle va se lancer
en Nouvelle-Calédonie elle pourra rester
au gouvernement ça c'est intéressant si
elle est élue il y a une brossa le
porte-parole du Parti communiste 3e
position sur la liste d'union de la
gauche et des écologistes à Paris et
puis toujours à Paris la mère du 7e
arrondissement est présente sur la liste
LR pour les sénatoriales Rachida Dati
mais alors en place non éligible elle
dit un symbole pour préparer la
reconquête de Paris il y a 12 postes de
sénateurs à pouvoir à Paris Nathalie
Moret pardon de vous poser une question
en pleine quinte de tout mais voilà ça
ça arrive je vous laisse le temps de de
reprendre votre souffle Paris pourquoi
Paris c'est un enjeu qui est intéressant
lors de ces élections sénatoriales
est-ce que c'est souvent une mine de
surprise en quelque sorte les élections
sénatoriales à Paris en tous les cas les
années où Paris et la région
Île-de-France est renouvelable c'est
toujours là où il y a le plus de focus
sur les élections sénatoriales et là
cette année Paris c'est assez
extraordinaire puisque il y a un cas qui
qui divise tout le monde c'est
l'élection ou la réélection de Julien
barjoton qui est donc Renaissance et qui
sur le papier effectivement
pour être réélu sauf que on connaît le
nombre de grands électeurs qu'il faut
pour être élu et sur le papier il les a
pas donc tout le le sens de de ce qui
nous anime tous aujourd'hui journaliste
politique c'est de savoir ce que vont
faire les grands électeurs Renaissance
est-ce qu'ils vont un proche de la
majorité est-ce qu'ils vont voter pour
Julien barjoton qui est leur sénateur ou
est-ce qu'au contraire ils vont soutenir
Pierre Charron qui se présente qui est
un élu LR qui se présente sur une liste
dissidente mais qui est proche du
président de la République qui dit qu'il
a le soutient lui aussi de des bases
qui sont en soutien donc
qu'est-ce que vont voter les gens c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très très
intéressant et de voir aussi après si
jamais monsieur Charron a été élu dans
quel groupe il va évidemment ce sera une
question subsidiaire en quelque sorte
Bruno cotress c'est on s'attend alors
évidemment être prudent on va faire
comme si l'élection été joué mais à une
élection quand même difficile pour la
majorité présidentielle qui est déjà
relativement faible au Sénat oui c'est
sûr que c'est une action difficile pour
la majorité présidentielle qui est une
conséquence assez mécanique de son
manque d'ancrage dans les territoires et
de son manque de succès aux différentes
élections qui se sont succédées depuis
l'élection municipale
élection départementale avec son
régional donc les gros bataillons des
grands électeurs ce sont les délégués
les conseils municipaux et on voit que
là le problème de ne pas être ancré dans
les dans les villes dans les communes
est un véritable obstacle et c'est vrai
que pour une formation politique
relativement récente puisque quand même
le parti présidentiel après tout
l'accident d'existence un peu plus de 6
ans d'existence
c'est compliqué
ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas bénéficié
d'une d'une vague bleu ciel au moment
des municipales de 2020 et ben donc là
ça va se payer très cher bien sûr au
moment des élections sénatoriales et
c'est vrai qu'Emmanuel Macron court
depuis le début après l'idée d'être
davantage ancré je pense pour deux
raisons et une première raison c'est de
montrer que ce parti n'est pas hors-sol
qu'il est ancré dans la société et
deuxième raison que ce parti peut
succéder peut survivre Emmanuel Macron
parce que s'il y a vraiment une question
que tout le monde se pose dans la
majorité c'est que deviendra le parti
présidentiel sans Emmanuel Macron un mot
de Yannick Jadot jérogibert ancien
candidat à la présidentielle pour Europe
Écologie Les Verts voilà ça va être une
personnalité enfin il y a peu de chances
que il se loupe et qui ne soit pas élu
sénateur ça va être une personnalité
évidemment marquante de je pense que les
personnalité comme ça soit au Sénat
parce que justement je parlais des
mutations tout à l'heure importante à
prendre en compte c'est tout à fait
quelqu'un qui peut tirer un certain
nombre de ses mutations et faire en
sorte que le travail du Sénat se porte
sur ses mutations donc je pense c'est
tout à fait important ça veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas d'autres d'ailleurs dans
d'autres partis politiques d'autres
futurs sénateurs qui n'ont pas aussi une
dimension écologique je pense d'ailleurs
que c'est pas inintéressant de voir à
quel point la dimension écologique
j'espère sera un peu un critère pour un
certain nombre d'électeurs dans les
choix
qui traversent une partie en partie les
partis politiques et les candidats parce
qu'il y a des candidats y compris moi je
pense aux républicains ou à la majorité
qui sont très engagés sur l'écologie et
d'autres beaucoup moins sauf que si la
gauche Mathieu part uni à Paris elle
part désuni un peu partout ailleurs
enfin ça c'est très simple en fait la
France insoumise souhaitait rééditer le
coût de la nups en disant oh les gars
regroupons-nous et puis comme ça on
gagnera plus de voix sauf que là où les
socialistes les communistes les Verts
étaient faibles oui gustatives ils sont
plutôt forts pour les sénatoriales parce
qu'ils ont des élus locaux donc ils ont
ces fameux grands électeurs que la
France insoumise n'a et donc du coup ils
les ont laissé tomber et la France
insoumise a dû présenter des candidats
alors dans beaucoup beaucoup de beaucoup
de circonscriptions et
la France insoumise aujourd'hui dit on
va s'arranger l'étiquette nupestres pour
ces sénatoriales nous sommes les vrais
vous savez ça fait penser un petit peu à
tout à toutes ces j'allais dire c'est
sec religieuses de début du
christianisme attention
de la vraie tunique donc voilà c'est qui
sera le plus lupus mais oui les insoumis
en fait si on fait simple comme ils ont
peu d'implantations locales parce que
pour eux une seule élection complète
était l'élection présidentielle bah il
se retrouve dans la même circonstance
que le parti d'Emmanuel Macron ils sont
peu implantés localement donc ils ont
peu de grands électeurs avec une
dimension vous l'avez un peu évoqué
Nathalie Moret mais bon il y a le
résultat du du scrutin c'est latorial et
puis ensuite il y a ce que les sénateurs
élus vont choisir vous parliez des des
sénateurs horizons est-ce que vous
décriviez à l'instant pour
un éventuel sénateur majorité présentiel
ça vaut aussi pour les sénatoires
horizons vers quel groupe vont-ils
s'amarrer est-ce qu'ils vont aller vers
le groupe de Claude madurée qui est
lui-même horizon et qui regroupe un
certain nombre de sénateurs qui ne sont
pas tous horizons mais dont certains
sont indépendants est-ce qu'il va aller
chez l'Union centriste de Hervé
Marseille par exemple est-ce qu'ils vont
aller pourquoi pas chez LR parce que ce
sont d'anciens VLR et que
c'est complètement fou en fait ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est que au Sénat vous
pouvez avoir au sein d'un même groupe
des gens qui ne pensent pas la même
chose ça paraît complètement fou de dire
ça mais en même temps c'est ce qui
permet aux sénateur de bien travailler
ensemble ce sont des groupes qui sont
moins politiques et d'ailleurs dans leur
dans leur on parle d'union centriste on
parle pas de groupes udi il y a le
groupe LR s'appelle LR mais autrement
les autres ont des appellations qui ne
sont pas les appellations de leur propre
partie je vais terminer avec vous Jérôme
Guibert là encore souvenir de grands
électeurs qu'est-ce qu'un grand électeur
attendent son sénateur qu'est-ce qui est
le plus important d'abord il attend que
les choix qu'il fasse au Sénat
correspond à peu près à ce qu'ils
pensent bon ça on sait bien qu'il y a en
même temps des contraintes politiques
etc mais il attend aussi que sur un
certain nombre de sujets locaux
importants et qui peuvent être débattus
qui peuvent être controversés et bien
qu'il le soutiennent dans dans la
possibilité de faire des choses y
compris vis-à-vis du préfet vis-à-vis
des évidemment en prenant position dans
la population donc c'est ce soutien y
compris très concrètement encore une
fois en allant des marchés les services
de la préfecture pour avoir un certain
nombre de subventions pour avoir un
certain nombre boire les services de
l'État et donc il y a moi je pense le
rôle je dirais le mot médiateur c'est
c'est le médiateur entre les territoires
les collectivités locales et l'État
et d'une certaine façon une partie de la
population merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat jérogibert
j'ai rappelé le titre de votre livre le
grand malentendu climatique livre publié
aux Éditions de l'Aube je vous dis à
demain pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public rendez-vous 18h et ou 22h vous
avez le choix sur l'antenne de public
Senna et notez que demain l'invité
Dorian Mancini dans la matinale c'est
Marc créneau le ministre de
l'Agriculture belle soirée à toutes et à
tous merci encore de votre fidélité
[Musique]